نحييكم من جديد مع اقتراب اللقاء المحتمل
التركي السوري الذي سيجمع بين قاده الدول
المعنيه بواسطه روسيا سيتحدد معه مسار
خريطه الاتصال بين انقره ودمشق تصريحات
خاصه بها قائد قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
قناه العربيه كشف فيها نيه تركيا تنفيذ
عمليه ذريه في مدينه عين العرب كوباني
وبان هذا التحرك قد يكون بقبول الطرفين
الروسي والسوري مظلوم عبدي قائد قوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه وفي المقابله الخاصه مع
قناه العربيه اكدوا ان اكد انه طلب من
نظام الاسد التصدي لايه عمليه عسكريه
تركيه محتمله لكنه لم يتلقى اي رد بحسب
قوله لكنه في نفس الوقت لم يستبعد
احتماليه اعتراض الجانب الروسيه والنظام
السوري على شاني عمليه تركيه في تل ابيض
ومنبج وليس عين العرب خصوصا وان جيشا نظام
قام بنشره نحو اسمه قاتل في مناطق العمليه
العسكريه التركيه المتوقعه في شمال السوري
وفقه مراقبين فان التقارب التركيه السوريه
يمكن ان يلقي بظلاله على تطورات الميدانيه
الحاصله في سوريا والعوده للمربع الاول من
الازمه خصوصا وان كل طرفا يسعى في الفتره
الحاليه لضمان مصالحه على الاراضي السوريه
وهنا نتحدث عن تركيا وروسيا وعن النظام
السوري كذلك
الاطراف
استنتجنا بعد تقييم الاوضاع ان تركيا تريد
سنه هجوم بريه على مناطقنا قبل الانتخابات
الرئاسيه والهجوم الذي سيركزون عليه سيكون
في كوباني ونتوقع ان تفضي المحادثات
الجاريه حاليا بين الروس والاطراف والنظام
السوري الى مساومه اوصف بشان عمليه في
كوباني
ونناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من دمشق عبر
سكايب عمر رحمون المتحدث
السوريه وبعد قليل سيظمن كذلك من اسطنبول
الدكتور بكير اتجاه مدير وما حديث اسطنبول
للفجر سابدا معك استاذ عمر ورحبك بدايه
ونحاول فهم هذه التصريحات اولا هذه
التصريحات التي خاصه بها قائد وقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه قناه العربيه وتحدث فيها عن
انه تواصل مع نظام السوري ولكن لم يكون
هناك جواب بخصوص همم القوات التركيه من
التوكل بره كيف نفهم عدم الرد هذا
تحيه لك يا استاذه المشاهدين طبعا يعني
تصريحات عبدي التي ادلى بها لقناه الحدث
والعربيه يعني هو قال بانه طلب لا شك بان
الطلبات القسديه تتوالى لكن الشيء الوحيد
الذي تحدث عنه وهو في الحقيقه قريب من
الواقع بان هناك
نيه تركيه اللي يشن عمليه بريه على عين
العرب هذا نعرفه في الحقيقه واتحدثنا عنه
كثيرا ونوايا الاحتلال التركي نوايا قائمه
سواء كانت هناك مفاوضات بين دمشق وانقره
او لم تكن هناك مهاوظات هناك
نيه تركيه لاحتلال المناطق الشماليه
لسوريا وهذا شيء مجرب يعني سابقه والان
والنيه قائمه فوضت وبدون مفاوضات هذا
بالجانب الجانب الثاني اما كلامه بان هناك
اعتراض سوري روسي على الحمله اذا كانت على
منبج وليس هناك اعتراض العرب
هوسات او احلام او يعني خيال يتحدث
سيد عمر هو قال اتوقع اتوقع ان لا يكون
هناك
موقف سوري روسي ايراني واضح ضد اي تدخل
عسكري بري او جوي تركي في الشمال السوري
سواء كان على عين العرب او تل رفعت او
منبج او اي منطقه سوريه هذا خط احمر سوري
سوري لا يمكن ان تفاضل او ان تجعل منطقه
افضل منطقه كل متر في الجغرافيا السوريه
ومتر له قيمته وهو كاي متر من غيره لكن
سوريا لها لها ابجديات ولها يعني مصالح لا
يمكن ان تعمل من اجل المصالح الاخرين يعني
شرق سوريا هي منطقه محتله لامريكا فاذا
كانت محتله لامريكا او محتله لتركيا هي
بالنهايه في المطار هي ارض سوريا محتله
يجب على الدوله السوريه على الجيش السوري
ان يعمل على تحرير هذه المنطقه اما ان
نعمل على حمايه الاحتلال الامريكي من
الاحتلال التركي يعني هذه امنيه
بمعنى من اسطنبول دكتور بكيرا توجان مدير
ما حد اسطنبول فكر دكتور بكير اهلا بك
معنا ضيفي يارا بان تركيا قادمه على هذه
مساء الانوار يرى ضيفي بان تركيا قادمه
على هذه العمليه او في نيتها على الاقل
عمل على هذه العمليه مهما كان الرفض او
الموافقه من اي طرف كان هل هذا دقيق
يعني نعم ولا في نفس الوقت نعم لانه همم
الى الان تنتظر تركيا ان تكون هناك انسحاب
وتفاهمات حول الاتفاقيات التي كانت 2019
بين روسيا وتركيا من طرف وبين تركيا و
الولايات المتحده من طرف اخر ولكن
ابعاد قوات همم يعني همم
حزب العمال الكردستاني
وحليفتها كلها مع الولايات المتحده من
الحدود السوريه التركيه بعمق 32 كيلو متر
ولكن الى الان لن نجد اي تقدم في هذه
الاتفاقيه علما بان تركيا قالت لو تسيطر
النظام وتكون هي المسؤوله ربما تكون
مقبوله ولكن الى الان حتى النظام للاسف
الشديد لا يستطيع حتى ان يحرك ساكنه في
هذه المناطق بالعكس هي التي تشجع هذه
العصابات الارهابيه على القمع والارهاب
لانه هناك اتفاقيات ضمنيا بينها وبين
النظام وليست بجديد منذ 203 وما زالت
مستمره هناك يعني هل الاسلام المشاركان في
خانه الشعب السوري
بان النظام هو الذي يحرك هذه المجموعات
كيف تعلق استاذ عمر
نعم هذه المجموعات من النظام بشكل او باخر
يعني هذا كلام سمعناه كثيرا لو كانت سوريا
تنتفع من هذه المجموعات لا حركتها لي لجلب
النفط والمحروقات للشعب السوري الذي يعاني
من البرد في هذا الشتاء لو كانت سوريا
مستفيده من هذه المجموعات او تسمع هذه
المجموعات بسوريا بالعكس
الاقتراح الثاني هذه المجموعات مخترقه
لصالح جهاز المخابرات التركي
وهناك يعني هذا القوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
فيها عده محاور محور يتبع للمهارات
الامريكيه محور التركيه محور الايران هناك
بعض
النفود للمخارات سوريا لكن المخابرات
التركيه لها اليد العليا واكبر دليل عندما
كانت قصدت في عفرين
وطالبتها سوريا بان يدخل الجيش السوري حتى
يمنع الاحتلال لكن الجناح الخاطئ
للمخابرات التركيه اصر ان يسلم المنطقه
عفرين لتركيا
في الحديث في كل مره عن عمليه البريه لا
تلقى رضا من روسيا من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
يا سيدتي انا قلت بان هناك مخطط تركي
لاحتلال الشمال السوري هذا الاحتلال لا
يمكن ان يكون لولا الذرائع واكبر ذريعه
لدخول تركيا واحتلال المنطقه هي وجود قصد
الان تحاول سوريا ان تخرج جسد حتى يستلم
الجيش السوري هذه المنطقه يمنع ويسح
الذريعه التركيه لكن قصد للاسف تتمنى اسد
لماذا جاءت الى سوريا قصد لماذا لجا الى
دمشق لانها تعلم يقينا بان امريكا اعطت
الضوء اكبر لتركيا لتشن العمليه العسكريه
تركيا اضعف واقل من ان تدخل الى اراضي
السوريه دون موافقه امريكيه واضحه قصد
فعلا ذلك فحاول ان تلعب على الخط الشرقي
روسي ايران سوريا مقابل ان يحمي الجيش
السوري هذه المنطقه لكن
المنطقه دكتور بكير هل هذا ما يحدث فعلا
تركيا تستعمل جسد كاتعلا لمحاوله تغيير
الديمغرافي واحتلال كما يقول ضيفي سوري
يعني للاسف هذا غير صحيح لسببين اولا اولا
كل الشعب السوري ان كان في الداخل او خارج
سوريا ان كانوا مع المخابرات او خارج
المخابرات يدركونا تماما بان حزد واخواتها
صنيعه النظام ليست بالجديد وحتى اجلان لما
كان يعني من عهد الاب الى عهد الابل الى
عهد الحفيد ربما هتستمر هذه يعني ورقه
وحتى المناطق التي انسحبت منها نظام
وتركتها لقد ولي اخواتها واضحه جدا هذا
ليس كلام
الاخوه الاكراد المتواجدين في شمال سوريا
كلهم يضربون يعني الى وقت قريب جدا يعني
اللعبه واضحه جدا للاسف الشديد جدا جدا
من المخابرات التركيه اين الحقيقه في كل
هذا
نعم نعم انا اوافق في هذه النقطه ال قصد
مخترقه من المخابرات التركيه ايضا الى
جانب المخابرات الدول الاخرى اييي يعني
سوريا حتى النظام مخترق من طرف المخابرات
التركيه ايضا ضيفك يدرك تماما هو وغيره مع
من كانوا يتعاملون والى اين الجهه اصبحوا
من هم لذلك هذه واضحه جدا هذه يعني الدوله
التركيه نعم لها قوه في داخل سوريا مع
جميع الفصائل التي الى جانبها والتي الى
همم يعني ضدها ان كانت النصره ان كانت جيش
النظام ان كانت جسد ان كانت اسد ان كانت
داعش ان كانت كلها بما فيها جيش النظام
الان لانه ضيفك يدرك تماما وهو يع- يعرف
جيدا كان مع من يعمل والان يعمل معمل يعرف
جيدا لذلك هذه ليست حجه الدوله قويه لابد
ان تكون لها ازرع في ذكر
الرجل
تعودنا على هذا الكلام المكرور يعني يقول
بان تركيا قوه كبرى وبانها مخترقه للجيش
السوري ومخترقه للجماعات المسلحه ومخترق
طيب قصد اذا كانت تهدد الامن القومي
التركي هي سيطره على 700 كيلو متر على
الحدود التركيه والدوله السوريه لن تكون
هنا كانت هناك جبهه النصره واحرار الشام
وداعش التي سلحتها ومولتها تركيا يعني لو
ان قصد كانت تجاور عصابه مسلحه من من من
100 شخص لم تستطع ان تسيطر على كامل
الحدود بين سوريا وتركيا فهذا الدليل واضح
وقاطع بان تركيا لو لم تكن على رضا
باستلام قصد بهذه المنطقه لم استطاعت قصد
يسيطر على 700 كم وتركيا تنظر بعينها ولا
تستطيع ان تفعل شيئا هنا نقول لان هذا
الكلام في الحقيقه القائد تهم على الاخرين
يعني هذا ليس محل البحث لكن نحن اليوم
نقول هناك مخطط تركي للاحتلال قتل بدراعه
المخترق لذراع تركيا تقدم ذريعه وسبب
رئيسه مقنع لتركيا
لفعل هذا الاحتلال ثم هناك اتفاق سوتشي
2019 وقعت قصد والتزمت باتفاق الذي تم
توقيعه بين بوتين واردوغان ان يستلم
الحدود الجيش السوري لكن هل استلم الجيش
السوري الحدود او هذه المنطقه حتى يسحب
الذريعه من تركيا قصد لم تفعل ذلك ربما
اذنت يعني في بعض الاحيان ودخلت بعض
العناصر للجيش السوري لكن يعني باسلحه
فرديه لم تدخل بابي سلاح الدوله لكي يحمي
هذه المنطقه من الاحتلال نحن في الحقيقه
في سوريا ننفذ الاحتلال التركي مهما كان
لونه مهما كان شكله وفي اي منطقه او لاي
منطقه كان لكن بالمقابل يعني ممكن ان نقبل
ان نقدم حمايه لقسم هكذا دون ان تسلم
الايراني توافقون على الاحتلال الامريكي
توافقون على الاحتلال الروسي توافقون على
الاحتلال
الفرنسيون على كل شيء الا ما عدد تركيا
الشعب السوري انت لانك تتعامل داره مع
روسيا مع النظام وتاره ضد النظام انت لا
تعرفك بانك تلعب على جميع الحلال وتكون
تركيا
لانك لا تستطيع ان تريده من تركيا لانها
رفضت ان تستعمل
لانها رمضانيه
تكون عميل لها لانك تعمل مجرد من اجل
الفلوس
في حلقات اخرى انتهى تماما وقت الملف
اشكركم جزيل الشكر من دمشق عمر رحمون
المتحدث باسم المصالحه السوريه ومن
اسطنبول دكتور
شكرا لكم